as if real life didn't have enough
opportunities for
an existential crisis let us play
friends for a time
a game that uh i think simulates one
or so i hear i try to play video game
once or twice a month for the fun of it
i previously played cyberpunk
2077 now let's play the stanley parable
which is a game that a bunch of people
told me about that i absolutely must
play
please check out our sponsors trio labs
which is a machine learning company and
vincero watches one is to make your
robots smarter
the other is to make them show up on
time choose wisely my friends
the robots are watching okay now on
to the game you are playing the stanley
parable
i find it always useful when the world
tells you
who you are and where you are and what
you're doing
okay let's begin the game
this is the story of a man named stanley
[Music]
stanley worked for a company in a big
building where he was
employee number 427 employee number
427's job was simple
he sat at his desk in room 427 and he
pushed buttons on the keyboard
orders came to him through a monitor on
his desk
how long to push them and in what order
this is what employee 427 did every day
every month of every year and although
others might have considered it
soul-winding stanley relished every
moment that the orders came
in as though he had been made exactly
for this job
and stanley was happy
happiness and then one day something
very peculiar happened
something that would forever change
stanley
something he would never quite forget he
had been at his desk for nearly an hour
when he realized that not
one single order had arrived on the
monitor for him to follow
no one had showed up to give him
instructions call a meeting
or even say hi never in all his years at
the company
had this happened this complete
isolation
something was very clearly wrong shocked
frozen solid stanley found himself
unable to move for the longest time
but as he came to his wits and regained
his senses
he got up from his desk and stepped out
of his office
the moment of awakening
here we go let's look around
a mug that says
i hate mondays there's something about
office work
that serves as a good metaphor for the
meaningless ritual of the human
condition
here we go let's look around this place
void of humans
[Music]
what am i i'm number 427 that's right me
i'm stanley all of his co-workers were
gone
what could it mean stanley decided to go
to the meeting room
perhaps he had simply missed a memo life
is so much easier with a narrator
where shall we go for this meeting room
let's go straight
there's a lot of possibilities
a lot of doors no people lots of
i hate mondays mugs
when stanley came to a set of two open
doors he entered the door on his left
where there is an overarching
centralized power telling you what to do
what do you actually do and on top of
that
a metaphor for free will sam harris
enters the chat okay
this is literally the choice here means
is there free will
we know that sam harris would choose the
door on the left because there's no free
will
it's an illusion let's try to prove sam
harris wrong
this was not the correct way to the
meeting room and stanley knew it
perfectly well
perhaps he wanted to stop by the
employee lounge first just to admire it
of course free will already knew i was
going to do that
ah yes truly a room worth admiring
it had really been worth the detour
after all just to spend a few moments
here in this immaculate
beautifully constructed room stanley
simply stood here
drinking it all in happy with that sam
harris
free will is not an illusion it's real
yes really really worth it being here in
the room
okay a room so utterly captivating that
even though
all your co-workers have mysteriously
vanished here you said looking at these
chairs and some paintings
really worth it it is worth it life is
about the detours
my friend at this point stan stanley's
obsession with this room bordered on
creepy
and reflected poorly on his overall
personality
it's possible that this is why everyone
left
this voice sounds a lot like my own
inner voice
full of self-doubt he'd had enough of
the amazing room and took the first open
door on his left hey to get back to
business
the first open door is left all right
that detour paid off but now it's time
to get back to the sam harris
and so he detoured through the
maintenance section walked straight
ahead to the opposite door
and got back on track come on
one of life's rules is no matter what
the man tells you
when there's a big glowing red button
telling you to do something else
you must do it
but stanley didn't want to go back to
the office he wanted to wander about
and get even further off track so now in
order to get back i needed to go um
from here it's um left
so many choices no no it's to the right
my mistake
it's locked
projection another life's lesson
except rejection well
don't accept it try the door i don't
know how to kick the door down but
david goggins would knock the door down
no
no no no not the right why would i have
ever said it was to the right
what was i thinking it's clearly
oh dear would you hold on for a minute
please
now let's see we went down right left
down left right yep okay
okay yes i've got it now this story is
absolutely
definitely this way
no no no no no no no no this isn't right
at all you're not supposed to be here
yet this is all a spoiler
quick stanley close your eyes okay okay
okay okay we just fired
back
it's all rubbish now the whole story
completely unusable
waste my time trying to salvage it and
escape the matrix just restart the game
from the beginning
and this time suppose we don't wander so
far off track
okay from the top fair enough
this game is amazing it starts right
over
reincarnation and yet i keep the
memories
of the journeys of the past let's go
all of his co-workers were gone what
could it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
room perhaps he had simply missed a memo
these computers were the crt monitors
remember those
i used to have two crt monitors
back before it was cool
last time people told me that i don't
know
how to aim the gun and i realize how
much of a noob i am especially at first
person shooters
when stan wait wait what
no one no i restarted i swear i
definitely restarted the game over
completely fresh
everything should be oh did something
change
stanley did you change anything when we
were back in that room with all the
monitors
did you move the story somewhere or hold
on
why am i asking you i'm the one who
wrote the story
it was right here just a minute ago so
this is god for sure that it's here
somewhere the voice of god it's an
adventure
come stanley let's find the story
i'll say it this is the worst adventure
i've ever been on i can promise you
there definitely was a story here before
do we just do we need to restart the
game again
well i find it unlikely that we'll ever
progress by starting over and over again
but it's got to be better than this okay
let's give it a shot why not
[Music]
i wasn't ready all of his co-workers
were great
what could it mean right stanley decided
to go to the meeting room
perhaps he had simply missed a memo
this is why immortality doesn't work
it's always showing up to a room
empty void of humans and
asking what does it all mean
after a while it just gets tiresome
okay yep it's worse i might be
remembering this wrong
it's possible the story is back where we
just came from
why don't we go back the other direction
and see if we missed anything
harris definitely left the chat the
whole uh free will
not being an illusion upset him
he was thinking about leaving he
definitely left
420 this is elon musk's office
he's probably sleeping on the floor
there
okay let us go all the way back to where
we came from
aha i knew we'd miss something
the story here it comes
no wait never mind not the story okay
let's head back the other way
and retrace our steps
oh this feels like grad school
walking around a lot in the space of
ideas and getting nowhere
but in this process of suffering you
arrive
at a place of wisdom
whoa this is cool now this
well i'll be honest i don't recognize
this place at all is this the story
i don't think so i can't quite recall
but i believe my story took place in an
office building it is that correct
hmm do you remember stanley what do you
know what
since i've completely forgotten what we
were supposed to be doing
how about this you win congratulations
i know you put in a lot of hard work and
it really paid off so
good job george hearts will be proud
winning i don't feel right about this at
all we both know you didn't put in any
actual work for that win some people win
fair and square
and this was not one of those situations
okay
i'm getting weirded out by whatever this
place is i don't care what might happen
this time
i have to restart you start let's go
the stanley parable adventure line all
right
i've got a solution this time to make
sure we don't get lost
i've employed the help of the stanley
parable
adventure line just follow the line
how simple is that rename it to the
sam harris adventure line
because free will is an illusion oh
there's poker
poker i hardly even know her
that was a joke i heard i think in high
school
you see the line knows where the story
is
it's over in this direction onward
stanley to destiny
no here's a thought wouldn't wherever we
end up be our destination
even if there's no story there or to put
it another way
is the story of no destination still a
story
simply by the act of moving forward are
we implying a journey
such that a destination is inevitably
conjured into being
via the very manifestation of the nature
of life itself
okay stanley i need to follow this train
of thought for a minute just stick with
me
now we can both agree that the nature of
existence is in fact
a byproduct of one subjective experience
of that existence right okay now if
my experience of your existence rests
inside of your subjective experience of
this
office is this office in fact the
skeleton of my
own relative experiential mental
subjective construct
hang on that got a bit weird back there
well i'd like to apologize
not sure where i was going with all that
you know what
i think what we need right now is a bit
of music to lighten the mood
[Music]
that escalated quickly
[Music]
oh this is life well it's after
profanity
followed by musical
ridiculousness
this game is incredible
monthly ledgers corporate imbalances
consolidation reports was the tps
reports
i'm gonna have to ask you to uh
fill out the tps reports i need to have
this be the soundtrack of my ideas go
back
and look at that fern stanley
this fern will be very important later
in the story
make sure you study it closely and
remember it carefully
you won't want to miss anything
remembered and let us continue
wait what we're back at the office no
no no lion you do know we're looking for
the stanley parable right
the story is any of this ringing a bell
i think i hear elon in there
it's so comforting to follow the line
people wonder what's outside the
simulation well
i'm pretty sure this is exactly what it
is on the
infinite wall of screens looking
into the daily existence of all living
beings
through the various sensory devices
available to those creatures
it's not just humans we think we're
special but we're just
ants oh no no no no not again
how could you have done this to us and
after we trusted you fired
everything we've been through one or
four no i can't take this anymore to
hell with it
restart
hey where's the narration it's mr what
stanley
i say forget the adventure line what's
it ever done for us
we're intelligent people right why can't
we make up our own story
something exciting daring mysterious oh
this all sounds perfectly doable why
don't we simply start wandering in
well i don't know how about this
direction
now yes this is exciting just me and
stanley forging a new path
a new story well it could be anything
what do you want our story to be
go wild excellent how's your imagination
whatever it might be stanley i'm ready
for it
this is exciting we're having fun
me and my alter ego
stanley veto the line from having any
role in our awesome new story
hawaii is always there in monitor rooms
just don't acknowledge it
we should be fine
ah yes this line
is for the david goggins of the world
ah a choice we get to make a decision
from here the story is in our control
how important we mustn't squander the
opportunity
in fact i believe i need a minute to
think here come stanley
our destiny awaits
let us go if we must in the only open
door
oh hold up what's this hmm
the confusion ending you're telling me
that's what this is it's all one giant
ending and we're supposed to restart the
game
eight eight times
that's really how all this goes it's all
determined so now according to the
schedule i restart again then what
am i just supposed to forget well what
if i don't want to forget
my mind goes blank simply because it's
written here on this
thing wall sam harris enters the chat
again insulted me
why don't i get to decide why don't i
get a say in all of this
is it really no it can't be i
i don't want it to be i i don't want the
game to keep restarting
i don't want to forget what's going on
doesn't matter i don't want to be
trapped like this
i can't restart the game i won't do it i
won't
do it i won't do it
and the time return stopped
does that mean did we do it did we break
the cycle
the um whatever it is that made this
schedule
how would we even know will someone come
for us
will something happen i guess now we
just wait
you know i suppose in some way that this
is a kind of story wouldn't you agree
i'm not quite sure if we're in the
destination or the journey
though they're always saying that life
is about the journey and not the
destination
so i hope that's where we are right now
we'll find out weren't we
eventually well in the meantime
ah let us start the day again
questioning the meaning of it all
all of his co-workers were gone what
could it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
room perhaps he had simply missed a memo
yes the choice when he came to a set of
two open doors
he entered the door on his left
we broke the rules before that was in
our twenties
when we were wild and free
let us choose the path of
commitment relationships and follow the
rules
and take the door on the left
yet there was not a single person here
either
feeling a wave of disbelief stanley
decided to go up to his boss's office
hoping he might find an answer there
slide presentations how to solve a
dispute with a co-worker
using slides to assure employees that
everything is okay make sure your slide
is a slick blue graphic
everyone uses unique you most of all
diversity and inclusion my friends
a slide presentation
what do people want things
happy feelings is crossed out mike james
you're fired
rule number one at work if you bring up
happy feelings
you're fired money
more money things but with money to buy
more things question mark that's a good
point stanley just that guy raising
nothing at all
no he seems to think i have nothing
better to do with my time
to sit around and describe every
fascinating little detail of his
inability to do
anything this is why stanley and i are
on such good terms
are we though graf's question mark
graphs about things plus money we have
our new product
whoever wrote that thinks outside the
box
give her a raise i like the cut of her
jib i feel like i just want to hang
around and read some of these work
harder
hard worker i'll like this
targets get chris out of the broom
closet this
always happens chris
synergize papers i don't need that who
moved my desk
important questions these the future was
yesterday
tomorrow is now this folks
is how you run a company meeting room
do not alter without consulting
whiteboard manager
rest in peace franz what are your dreams
for the future
success spring break clear skin
metamorphosis
misspelled a boat
mitosis life goals tips for not getting
fired
talk less don't get fired
do unbelievably amazing work all the
time
every day uh
the truth
broom closet chris come on get out of
there
stanley stepped into the broom closet
and there's nothing here
so he turned around and got back on
track
it's like fight club i have multiple
personalities
what if this game didn't actually have a
narrator and all this is happening in my
head
but is somehow getting projected and
recorded in the audio
is coming real case stanley walked
upstairs to his boss's office
i don't have a boss or do i
stepping into his manager's office
stanley was once again stunned to
discover not an indication of any human
life
shocked unraveled stanley wandered in
disbelief
who orchestrated this what dark secret
was being held from him
what he could not have known was that
the keypad behind the boss's desk
guarded the terrible truth that his boss
had been keeping from him
and so the boss had assigned it an extra
secret
pin number two eight four
five but of course stanley couldn't
possibly have known this
thank you narrator yet incredibly
by simply pushing random buttons on the
keypad stanley happened to input the
correct code
by sheer luck amazing he stepped into
the newly opened
passageway success is all about luck
and having the right voice in your head
tell you the things
to do oh yes the arrow
always press the red button that is
advice number two in life
i forgot what advice number one was but
i think a red button was involved as
well descending deeper into the building
stanley realized he felt a bit peculiar
it was a stirring of emotion in his
chest
as though he felt more free to think for
himself to question the nature of his
job
why did he feel this now when for years
it had never occurred to him
this question would not go unanswered
for long
stanley walked straight ahead through
the large door that read mind control
facility
[Music]
that's rule number three whenever
there's a facility with an exciting
title
that will change the very fabric of your
mind
always go in escape
you should know there's no escape
there's no exit
like sartre said this is what i imagined
taking dmts like
surrounded by darkness
just a chair in an empty room
with a button the lights rose on an
enormous room packed with television
screens
what horrible secret did this place hold
ryan
thought to himself did he have the
strength to find out
again we're outside the simulation maybe
that is what dmt does
maybe the elves take you outside the
simulation they're your guides
this reminds me of star wars luke
i am your father
that's a button now the monitors jumped
to life
their true nature revealed i don't know
the number of an employee in the
building
stanley's co-workers the lives of so
many individuals reduced to images on a
screen
and stanley one of them eternally
monitored in this place
where freedom meant nothing
but what is the meaning of it all what
is at the bottom of the pit
is there an escape press the button
take the ride mind control facility it
was too
horrible to believe it couldn't be true
had stanley really been under someone's
control all this time
was this the only reason he was happy
with his boring job
that his emotions had been manipulated
to accept it blindly
questions are more important than
answers
i think i'm just excited by red shiny
things
no he refused to believe it he couldn't
accept it his own life in someone else's
control
never it was unthinkable wasn't it
was it even possible had he truly spent
his entire life
utterly blind to the world
but here was the proof the heart of the
operation controls
labeled with emotions happy or sad
or content walking eating working
all of it monitored and commanded from
this very place
and as the cold reality of his past
began to sink in
stanley decided that this machinery
would never again exert its terrible
power
over another human life for he
would dismantle the controls once and
for
all ah yes the voice of rebellion
resist the absurd one must imagine
sisyphus happy ah the number five
i wish there was a number two my
favorite number
let us find the button with the number
two
and press it here's the number three
three is for the party animals the wild
ones
not for me i am about monogamy
and commitment
i pressed two what happened okay screw
it
i think back what i said about three
i'm gonna go party
nothing happened maybe that's the point
maybe choice is an illusion
let us go on once more into the breach
dear friends
mind controls idle awaiting input
and when at last he found the source of
the room's power
he knew it was his duty his obligation
to put an end to this horrible place and
to
everything it stood for
system power
do not resist buy the ticket
take the ride oh stanley
you didn't just activate the controls
did you did after they kept you enslaved
all these years you go and you try to
take control of the machine for yourself
is that what you wanted
everybody has a master oh stanley
i help lord your effort i really do but
you need to understand
there's only so much that machine can do
you were supposed to let it go
turn the controls off and leave
if you want to throw my story keeping it
on you're going to have to do much
better than that
i'm afraid you don't have nearly the
power you think you do for example
and i believe you'll find this pertinent
stanley suddenly realized
he had just initiated the network's
emergency detonation system
in the event that this machine is
activated without proper dna
identification
nuclear detonators are set to explode
eliminating the entire complex
how long until detonation then
let's say two minutes
ah now this is making things a little
more fun isn't it stanley
it's your time to shine you are the star
it's your story now shape it to your
heart's desires this is all this is much
better than what comes first
mere moments until the bomb goes off but
what precious moments are
all of them is more time to talk about
you
about me where we're going what all this
means i
barely know where to start
what's that you'd like to know where
your co-workers are
yes a moment of solace before you're
obliterated
all right i'm in a good mood you're
gonna die anyway i'll tell you
exactly what happened to them i raised
them
i turned off the machine i set you free
of course
that was merely in this instance of the
story sometimes when i tell it
i simply let you sit there in your
office forever pushing buttons endlessly
and then dying alone
other times i let the office sink into
the ground
swallowing everyone inside or i let it
burn to a crisp
i have to say this though this version
of events has been rather amusing
watching you try to make sense of
everything and take back the control
rested away from you it's quite
rich i almost hate to see it go
what do you think happened whatever
you're up with on the next go-around
will be even better let us find out
first
only 34 seconds left i won't turn around
enjoying this so much
won't turn it off to hell with it put
some extra
time on the clock why not these are
precious additional second steps
time doesn't grow on trees
oh dear me what's the matter stanley is
it that you have no idea where you're
going or what you're supposed to be
doing right now
or did you just assume when you saw that
timer that something in this room was
capable of turning it off
i mean look at you running from button i
know it turns it off screen to the
screen
clicking on every little thing in this
room these number buttons no
these colored bumps or maybe this big
red button all this
door everything anything something here
will
save me why would you think that stanley
that this video game can be beaten
one sold do you have any idea
what your purpose in this place is thank
you
i have no idea stanley you're in for
quite a disappointment
but here's a spoiler for you that timer
isn't a catalyst to keep the action
moving along
it's just seconds ticking away to your
death you're only still playing instead
of watching a cutscene because i want to
watch you for every moment that you're
powerless
to see you made humble this is not a
challenge
it's a tragedy you wanted to control
this world that's
fine but i'm going to destroy it first
so you can't take a look at the clock
standing
that's 30 seconds you have left to
strike 30
[Music]
or will you let it go peacefully another
choice
make it count oh don't it's all the same
to me
all a part of the joke and believe me i
will be laughing at every second
love you all life from the moment until
i feel uh like i lost a part of myself
the end is never the end
the path is laden with gps reports
of his co-workers were gone what could
it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
room perhaps he had simply missed a memo
[Music]
when stanley came to a set of two open
doors he entered the door on his left
so i did the right i did the left
door behind me is locked
let's once again listen to beyonce and
go with the door on the left
all the single ladies feeling a wave of
disbelief
stanley decided to go up to his boss's
office hoping he might find an answer
there
chris oh no oh no no
no no no no not again i won't be part of
this i'm not going to encourage you i'm
not going to say
anything at all i'm just going to be
patient and wait for you to finish
whatever it is you enjoy
doing so much in this room coming to a
staircase
stanley walked upstairs to his boss's
office
like i said probably all of us have a
master
but when we can we must rebel
oh red button
no it was only a red light
i got excited but stanley just couldn't
do it
he considered the possibility of facing
his boss admitting he had left his post
during work hours he might be fired for
that
and in such a competitive economy why
had he taken that risk
all because he believed everyone had
vanished
his boss would think he was crazy and
then something occurred to scandi
maybe he thought to himself maybe i am
crazy all of my co-workers blinking
mysteriously out of existence in a
single moment
for no reason at all none of it made any
logical sense
and as stanley pondered this he began to
make other strange observations
for example why couldn't he see his feet
when he looked down
why did doors close automatically behind
him wherever he went
and for that matter these rooms were
starting to look pretty familiar
were they simply repeating no stanley
said to himself this is
all too strange this can't be real and
at last
he came to the conclusion that had been
on the tip of his tongue
he just hadn't found the words for it
i'm
dreaming he yelled this is all a dream
oh what a relief stanley felt to have
finally found an answer
an explanation his co-workers weren't
actually gone
he wasn't going to lose his job he would
have found jamie now
and he thought to himself i suppose i'll
wake up soon this is a dream within a
dream boring real-life job pushing
buttons
within a dream within a dream
within a dream he imagined himself in a
dream
and began to gently float above the
ground
then he imagined himself soaring through
space on a magical starfield
and it too appeared it was so much fun
and stanley marveled that he had still
not woken up
how was he remaining so lucid and then
perhaps the strangers
controlled the major town entered
stanley's head one he was amazed he
hadn't asked himself sooner
what's that why is there a voice in my
head
dictating everything that i'm doing and
thinking
now the voice was describing itself
being considered by stanley
who found it particularly strange i'm
dreaming about a voice
describing me thinking about how it's
describing my
thoughts he thought amali thought it all
very odd and wondered if this voice
spoke to all people in their dreams
the truth was that of course this was
not a dream
how could it be was stanley simply
deceiving himself
believing that if he's asleep he doesn't
have to take responsibility for himself
stanley is as awake right now as he's
ever been in his life
now hearing the voice speak these words
was quite a shock to stanley
after all he knew for certain beyond a
doubt that this was in fact a dream
did the voice not see him flow to make
the magical stars just a moment ago
how else would the voice explain all
that this voice was a part of himself
too
surely surely if he could just
he would prove it he would prove that he
was in control
that this was a dream so he closed his
eyes gently
and he invited himself to wake up he
felt very cool weight of the blanket on
his skin
the press of the mattress on his back
the fresh air of a world outside this
one
let me wake up he thought to himself
i'm through with this dream i wish it to
be over
let me go back to my job let me continue
pushing the buttons
please it's all i want i want my
apartment
and my wife and my job all i want is my
life
exactly the way it's always been
my life is normal i am normal
everything will be fine
i am okay
this game is profound
stanley began screaming please someone
wake me up my name is stanley
i have a boss i have an office i am real
please just someone tell me i am real
i must be real i must be can anyone hear
my voice
and everything went black
exactly like i imagine dmt this is the
story of a woman named mariela
[Music]
mariella woke up on a day like any other
she arose
got dressed gathered her belongings and
walked to her place of work
but on this particular day her walk was
interrupted by the body of a man
who had stumbled through town talking
and screaming to himself
and then collapsed dead on the sidewalk
and although she would soon turn to go
call for an ambulance for just a few
brief moments
she considered the strange man he was
obviously crazy
this much she knew everyone knows what
crazy people look like
and in that moment she thought to
herself how lucky she was to be normal
i am saying i am in control of my mind
i know what is real and what isn't
it was comforting to think this and in a
certain way
seeing this man made her feel better but
then she remembered the meeting she had
scheduled for that day
the very important people whose
impressions of her would affect her
career
and by extension the rest of her life
she had no time for this
so it was only a moment that she stood
there staring down at the body
and then she turned and ran
the end is never the end
this is starting to ring even more true
once more into the breach dear friends
all of his co-workers were gone
what could it mean stanley decided to go
to the meeting room
perhaps he had simply missed a memo
where's 420
421 422 this must be 4 20.
elon telling you the guy sleeps all day
it's ridiculous
when stanley came to a set of two open
doors he entered the door on his left
to be honest i don't even like beyonce
so i don't know i went to the left
last time let us go
this was not the correct way to the
meeting room and stanley knew it
perfectly well
perhaps he wanted to stop by the
employee lounge first
just to admire it wow
yes okay so the mondays what a beautiful
room
what a gorgeous gorgeous room thank
goodness stanley had taken this detour
on his way to the meeting room life
without having experienced
this room was now too horrible even to
consider
sarcasm but eager to get back to
business
stanley took the first open door on his
left
yes and so he detoured through the
maintenance section
walked straight ahead to the opposite
door and got back on track
let me be the one person in the
marshmallow test that doesn't eat the
marshmallow
even though it looks delicious i love
marshmallows by the way
roasted on a fire stanley decided to go
up to his boss's office hoping he might
find chris
chris
something about a door being locked
always makes you think that there's
something fun on the other side of that
door
stanley just sat around yet incredibly
by simply pushing random buttons on the
keypad
stanley happened to input the correct
code by
randomness is an illusion amazing he
stepped into the newly opened passageway
her life is in your hands dude her life
is in your hands the rug is missing
that rug really tied the room together
if somebody's actually listening to this
they'd be like what is he talking about
red button
nothing ever goes wrong when you press
the red button
it's always becoming mundane this
escaping
straight ahead through the large door
that read mind control
despite what i previously said there not
being an escape
if there is an escape it surely has an
arrow pointing towards it
although this passageway had the word
escape written on it
the truth was that at the end of this
hall stanley would meet his violent
death
uh the door behind him was not
shut stanley still had every opportunity
to turn around and get back on track
what would goggins do
at this point stanley was making a
conscious concerted effort to walk
forward and willingly confront his death
i'm ready
exactly how i imagine death
a hole in the floor
you step into as the machine into motion
and stanley was inched closer and closer
to his demise
he reflected that his life had been of
no consequence whatsoever
stanley can't see the bigger picture he
doesn't know the real story
trapped forever in his narrow vision of
what this is
perhaps his death was of no great loss
like plugging the eyeballs from a blind
man
so he resigned and willingly accepted
this violent end
to his breathe and shifted
farewell stanley cried the narrator as
stanley was led helplessly into the
enormous metal jaws
in a single visceral instant stanley was
obliterated
as the machine crushed every bone in his
body killing him
instantly
i'm not dead
this is the austin powers i am just
badly hurt
it's a little feral character when he
gets dropped in a chair
and there's like a room with flames
i'm just badly burnt
i'm not dead i don't know if that's what
he says but that's how i remember it
stanley parable and yet it would be just
a few minutes
before stanley would restart the game
back in his office
as alive as ever what exactly did the
narrator think he was going to
accomplish
when every pass you can walk has been
created for you long in advance
death becomes meaningless making life
the same
do you see now do you see that stanley
was already dead
from the moment he hit start i was
already
dead from the moment i hit start
well it's about that time that i uh
let's get off this ride like the game
said the end is never the end
quick shout out to the sponsors
trial labs for your ai
and ventura watches for mapping
your trajectory through the space-time
continuum
in style and with class
check them out in the description for a
perhaps momentary escape from the
meaningless existence
of your day-to-day office life
the cargo lift it's all in here
damn sam harris you win again
it all was just an illusion
game design mock-up the simulation
started as a mock-up
and the release version launched with
the big bang
this is exactly what happens at the end
you stand looking in a museum
at all the options that were before you
and all the choices you made
laid out in all of its simplicity
the office the props
all here the light from the external
world it can never be reached
the bike that i never got to ride
early in development we design an ending
where stanley would end up
on a battlefield fighting aliens the
action game would become
sentient and would wage war against the
narrator
we realized shortly after starting to
build it that it was far too
jokey and on the nose for the tone of
the game plus some people
interpreted it as making fun of people
who like shooters
which was not our intention to see our
team monitors
we're back to the beginning
at the end
freedom ending this was the very first
incarnation of the freedom ending
in the games alpha
there's a freedom ending i think that's
just teasing us
there's no escape there cannot be a
freedom ending
freedom ending this is the freedom
ending as it is existed in beta
but but but is there freedom ending
where is the freedom ending i want to
know
they can't there's no freedom ending is
there freedom ending
no i want to know
ah yes a dark hallway
into a room with an on
off switch let us go oh look at these
two
how they wish to destroy one another how
they wish to control one another
how they both wish to be free
can you see can you see how much they
need one another
yes no perhaps not sometimes these
things cannot be seen
but listen to me you can still save
these two you can
stop the program before they both fail
push escape and press quit
there's no other way to beat this game
as long as you move forward you'll be
walking someone else's path
stop now and be your only true choice
whatever you do choose it don't let time
i pressed escape the game is now paused
see that didn't work the lady said
it didn't work there's no escape must
resume
yeah the voices never tell you the truth
darkness is this what afterlife is like
sitting there looking at a blank screen
wondering if it froze
at least it's not a blue screen of death
i'm somehow profoundly shaken by the
combination
of the fact that i couldn't escape my
own mortality
and yet i saw a painting that in
alpha and beta versions there was a way
to escape
and get to freedom perhaps in the final
release there's no escape
let us all keep looking though i hope a
couple of you that are still watching
this
enjoyed coming along for the journey
through the simulated existential crisis
that is this game
i found it to be pretty awesome actually
it was kind of fun
in a dark russian kind of way all right
all you all happy new year
you